yeah all right I'm really honest with
you I'm kind of buzzed right now because
I was drinking rum and coke and I was
editing videos editing my 13 hours video
it was like oh [ __ ] I should do a video
on that trailer I saw tonight that's
right I filmed this last night and
you're watching it today this is as
close to time-travel as we will ever get
I really should I never do videos buzzed
or drunk with here we are so sitting
there watching 13 hours and the trailers
came on this one trailer came on I just
I needed to talk about I wanted to talk
about it and people were like hey do a
video on that trailer and I was like
okay I want to they want to see it it's
a perfect marriage but this trailer
starts out before I even say the title
the title is in the title of this video
it kind of makes the counterproductive
those trailer starts out is John Goodman
and Mary Elizabeth Winstead and his
other dude I don't know and they're all
just hanging out in their 1960s look at
home they're doing puzzles or just just
hanging out they said oh I brought to
you by bad robot and I was like this is
kind of a different vibe this doesn't
feel like Star Trek or Star Wars and
what is this your rumblings above like
their ceiling shaking you're like are
they in a bomb shelters first time you
kind of get the vibe they're in a bomb
shelter and then the girl takes his
bottle just BAM and beats John Goodwin
over the head with it you're like oh my
god it's John Goodman like Johnny Drama
from 24 season - is he like he's he
kidnapped these people he's keeping them
in this bomb shelter just you know cuz
he wants a family or something I don't
know this is what I was thinking then
she hauls ass up the stairs and John
Goodman's coming after her and you're
like go go go get out of here this
[ __ ] gonna kill you then she as this
is airlock 101 you get through the first
door and then you're in this space you
got to get through the second door so
you get to the first door and she locks
it behind her and he's like no don't go
you'll kill us all she looks out the
window of her bomb shelter and she's
like she's a sphere is in her eyes and
then boom the titled Cloverfield comes
out in this 10 Cloverfield Lane is the
time limit is that right let me check
yep 10 Cloverfield Lane no it's just 10
Cloverfield Lane and he says hey by the
way this is coming up in March this
movie is coming out two months from now
that just blew my mind that's baffling
it's it's most of the reason I want to
talk about this movie or that Lisa's
trailer because this
logical Wonderland nothing has ever kept
secret everyone knows every movie that's
coming out everyone knows every trailer
that's coming out everyone knows what's
happening all the time and I kind of
missed that world of mystery back before
the internet social media was as huge as
it is now the time where you can make a
movie and keep it secret and no one
really knew what it was about I thought
that was long gone dead and buried it is
10 Cloverfield Lane is coming out two
months from now it's a big deal it's a
Cloverfield sequel no one knew [ __ ]
about it no one knew this thing was a
thing until now until it actually the
trailer dropped on 13 hours and it made
me happy made me happy because it showed
me that movies can be kept secret until
two months before they come out and to
be fair I don't even know if this is
actually a sequel to Cloverfield it's
just called 10 Cloverfield Lane that
happens to be by bad robot happens to be
produced by JJ Abrams those are the
facts that line up and if for nothing
else at the very least it's in the same
world as Cloverfield there's some sort
of Cloverfield spin-off of sorts saying
you heard rumblings and you saw their
ceiling rumbles so it's like alright
rumblings were happening to the earth so
is it are they monster footsteps or is
it shelling that's happening is it like
the military bombing things it could be
that Cloverfield is the thematic title
to things that happen in the world of
Cloverfield so in Cloverfield it was a
monster maybe this one's a virus or
zombies of some sort I don't know and I
love the fact that I just don't know I
suppose I can go on the internet
somewhere some websites on Wikipedia
something has the synopsis of this movie
but I don't want to look at it I don't
want to know it I don't want to do it
the fact that this movie was kept so
secret this trailer was kept so secret
up until two months before the movie
actually comes out just shows me that
they don't want you to know all I know
is John Goodman's in a bomb shelter with
two younger people and one of them wants
the [ __ ] out of there and rumbling is
happening Cloverfield sequel and I'm
pumped the 10 Cloverfield Lane trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it blew my mind but whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if it like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more I love rum and coke